[موسيقى]
الفن التشكيلي هو الفن الشاغل الذي نسلط
به ونعبر من خلاله ونجسد من خلاله عن ما
شاهد القضيه من جرائم والم وحصار وركام من
قبل هذا الاحتلال المجرم ومن
رحم المعاناه والالم والحصار نخرج الامل
والفن والانتصار
رساله رسالتنا من خلال الريشه ومن خلال
[موسيقى]
الصوره هذه موجوده في نفس المكان اللي
كانوا اطفالي متواجدين فيه واللي
بيتواجدوا فيه والحمد لله انهم ما نصبوا
مكروه ولهذا المكان مكانهم ومكان
الالعابهم وكانوا موجودين وبراءه الطفل
الموجوده فيه للاسف تحولت الى مكان حرب
مكان جريمه حرب
[موسيقى]
نا ورسلتنا نظهر للعالم كله انه احنا من
مكان الركام دمار بنقدر نوصل رساله
بلوحه فنيه طبعا بتعبر عن معاناتنا معاناه
شعبنا بنوصل للعالم كلهيته رساله
بالعالم احنا الشعب الوحيد لحتى الان اللي
تحت الاحتلال
[موسيقى]
هنا بعض الالعاب الاطفال والتي قصفت هنا
ايضا ستجد صواريخ الاحتلال التي قطف
جمعنا هذه المقتنيات المتناثره بعد هذا
القصر هذا عباره عن صاروخ واحد فقط دمر حي
كامل دمر تقريبا 10 عائلات كانت تسكن هذا
الحي بصاروخ امريكي بمعدات صهيونيه
[موسيقى]